so I'm really not a conspiracy theorist
I always look for the least complex
answer for any sort of odd phenomenon
but I definitely am a coincidence
noticer and it doesn't necessarily mean
that there is some secret shadowy group
of people that are doing all sorts of
Nefarious things at the very least
though there is no such thing as
coincidences you know modern Libs
believe that every strange it no matter
how big the miracle is no matter how in
your face some kind of Miracle is
they'll say oh it's just random chance
for Christians though for people who are
traditionally religious there's no such
thing as coincidences because there's
Providence and there's an order to the
universe now what's going on in this
case in this really bizarre
incident in East Palestine Ohio
is that just the broad order of the
universe is that just random chance or
something else I don't know